oh yeah we're gonna start off just by
M&M minutes and you know what we're
coming from a place of ignorance this
episode is just as much about us
enlightening ourselves as it is about us
entertaining you so go easy on us yeah
this episode's gonna be great talking
about the wonderful RuPaul who I love so
much I mean you know if you watch our
morning show every day
Wepa in the morning available at
patreon.com slash bay ridge boys we have
a segment called worked at girl we're
honest and I sing and dance to her
favorite to her famous song work and
that's only part of it the real thing to
remember is that segment is all about
celebrating women and those who identify
as women and their accomplishments
throughout history because let me tell
you something you're coming on this
podcast Low Energy she got two [ __ ]
options right now and two options only
okay bobis listen to me either I'm gonna
come over there and let's start
caressing you [ __ ] nut sack okay well
I'm gonna give you an Eskimo kiss on
your belly button even though I know the
word Eskimo is derogatory right now and
I'm sorry about that so which is gonna
be you want to get you nutsack your
nutsack tickled or your bellybutton kiss
by an Eskimo I'm good I'm gonna go for
ago for neither is there a third option
we're going all the way to San Francisco
in spirit for one of the most I would
say V would you call him Wow
he goes by him RuPaul that's his pronoun
as maybe the most influential drag queen
of all time I would say Father's Day
during Pride Month it's like right I
mean we can't writ look if we're gonna
rip down George Washington can we also
rip down some of these patriarchal
nuclear family [ __ ] holidays
yeah I mean that's so [ __ ] 1987
yeah or even 1777 to even call someone
father or celebrate them what are we
celebrating exactly what are we
celebrating right a dad yeah you know
what dad's did they created a patriarchy
you know what that patriarchy did okay
it oppressed people so let's [ __ ] get
rid of it I want to send my kid to a
school that teaches that kid had a hate
America and hate the father who pays for
that school yeah that's great that's
would you choke it to RuPaul as a guy
you mean what I jerked the RuPaul again
yeah I've been a lot better [ __ ] snap
yes yes through it he said you can call
me he you could call me she you could
call me Regis and Kathie Lee I don't
care just as long as you call me car huh
cuz being [ __ ] fine here's the thing
if you're gay you're lucky you're
liberated you're liberated from these
[ __ ] straight goddamn limit [ __ ]
love it I mean my hands moving again
yeah yeah his [ __ ] movie that's how I
know you're Chrissy chaos cuz it's
quarantine it's my baby's mama the kid
RuPaul she came to New York City and in
the 80s no but she said she doesn't
matter rourou doesn't matter that she
wouldn't yeah rourou baby doesn't matter
in the mid-1980s ruh baby left the south
and headed to New York City and became
part of a new festival known as a wig
stock and then rue came to New York to
New York and became that popular fixture
in the nightclub because the nightclubs
in the 80s must have been fun fun fun
your brother your $3 bill brother was
probably bopping around in the 1980s
nightclub scene he may have been bumped
into RuPaul seriously he might have what
I love about the gay community is how
variegated it is there's so much in the
spectrum it's like when your straight
guy it's kind of boring we're just kind
of guys you know some of us read and
some of us don't I mean cuz the gay
world is really a Vegas buffet and to
the laughs a turn to the right do you
look let's put it on the runway
work it girl do you'll see the runway
turn to the right
sashay Shantay so fierce became such an
anthem that she just skyrocketed to
success and coke pop-culture fame she
got a talk show on MTV us she was
interviewing yes I'm celebrities RuPaul
was here she has arrived yeah yeah yes
so she made her feature film debut in
Spike Lee's um Crooklyn good movie Spike
Lee's Crooklyn she her talk show a
variety show on vh1 in 1996 it what went
through 98 but then she really popped I
mean really [ __ ] pop for our new fans
in 2009 with the debut of the
long-running reality TV competition
RuPaul's Drag Race which I was a fan of
yeah here's the thing about I tried to
get in RuPaul RuPaul skyrocket in the
90s make no mistake she was unlike the
cover of magazines and stuff
she skyrocketed nineties then there was
this kind of like plateau period she put
out a couple more albums they didn't do
his grade even though one of the songs
hit the chart she was making music I
mean she did like three albums a girl
gets to Italy in America you can be
anything you want to be somebody just
made her a musician and she's the
musicians America there it is yes go
ahead go ahead young his quote is we are
all born naked and the rest is drag baby
very true true soon as you put clothes
on your and drag wearing drag right now
maybe a different kind of drag than what
you're used to but we under a go boom
it's kind of like the modern form of
what Shakespeare said the world's a
stage and we're all just playing apart
cuz we're not we're all just dressing up
for each other
who's what's the true us yeah what's the
true you the true make drew you you're
pretty close to the true you I've say
I'm pretty close to the true mean I
think the true me I think the true me is
a guy who is very comfortable with
himself
I think getting turned on by men but you
don't sexually attracted what does it
mean you're turned on by men you always
fly by that thank you guys for watching
don't forget to subscribe also turn on
alerts more to come tell
absolutely and go to patreon.com/scishow
a rich boys to join the matriarchal
where things get really wild
[Music]